>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Tomoko Steen: Welcome, everyone.
Today's event is sponsored
by the Science, Technology,
and Business Division, here
at the Library of Congress.
I'm Tomoko Steen and this is
specialist, here at the Library.
And this is one of the
Science Literacies.
And today's topic is
molecular anthropology.
Is that right?
And genetics.
Anthropology, genetics.
Today's speaker, Doctor
Adam Wilkins.
He's a geneticist and author.
He has also wrote several
books, previously.
And he has been trained
as a geneticist,
especially microbiogenetics
[phonetic].
And he has worked on a
that, a few of those times.
But he turned himself into the more
science writing and public outreach.
He has been the editor of the
''BioEssays'' [inaudible] journal.
As well as, now he is the editor
of the Perspective section
of the Genetics, which is the
probably the leading journal
for the field of genetics.
And Doctor Wilkins have done
PhD at University of Washington.
And so, he was born
in Columbus, Ohio.
But currently, he is
at Humboldt University.
So, a lot of people ask me,
''Is he a German?'' Surely,
he's American, I guess.
But it's going to be
an interesting talk.
And we have a book, outside.
So, after this we have
a book signing.
So, if you are interested, take
a look at the book, as well.
And before [inaudible], maybe we
just invite speaker, Doctor Wilkins.
[ Applause ]
>> Adam Wilkins: Tamoko, thank you
very much, of that introduction.
And even more, I'd like to thank
you and the Library of Congress
for inviting me to come speak.
It really is an honor and
a privilege to be here.
The Library of Congress is a
bastion of American civilization
and as such, the defender of
fundamental American values.
And those need defense
as much today,
as they have at any other time.
So, my topic is indeed the
evolution of the human face.
Or if we were to put it in terms
that Rudyard Kipling might like,
how our species acquired its face.
As background, too.
Before I get into the
subject itself,
I'd just like to say a little bit
about how I got interested in it.
As Tomoko said, my
background is in other things,
particularly microbial genetics.
But I've always been
interested in evolution.
And I think it's safe to say that
for most of the 20th century,
evolutionary biology had a
very self-consistent reasonable
logical theory.
But there is a real
lack of specificity
to how much one could say about
specific evolutionary changes,
for which there was evidence.
But we could not tie specific
genes and genetic factors
to particular evolutionary changes.
So, in a way it was a kind of.
It was a good theory, but it
lacked a certain kind of rigor.
But beginning in the 1970s and
acquiring strength in the 1980s,
it began to be possible to
isolate genes, specifically.
And make very specific hypotheses
about what particular genes
were doing in evolution.
Not the least in how
particular genes were responsible
for particular traits
in different organisms.
And for some of the interest
in evolution or biology,
this is the prospect
of scientific heaven.
To be able to really
have good concrete ideas
about what genes might be involved
in evolutionary changes
of particular kinds.
So, I wasn't involved as a
laboratory scientist, in this work.
But I was very interested in
it, and I wrote commentaries.
And I finally, wrote a book
that summed up the state
of the field, which
came out in 2002.
And shortly after the book became
published, I found myself thinking,
''Well, how might this
kind of thinking apply
to human evolution?'' We are a
distinctive looking animal species.
We are animals.
Of course, we are a lot more.
Our species is unique
in what it does
in the world, and what it has done.
But surely, there would be a
scope, I felt, for this new branch
of evolutionary biology, called
evolutionary developmental biology.
To say something interesting
about humans, human evolution.
And surely, after having
this thought, I felt, ''Ah,
the human face might be a
particularly interesting aspect
of human characteristics,
of human biology,
to focus on.'' It was more
just a hunch and a feeling.
Because at the time, actually
there was very little one could say
about the genes that are involved
in constructing the human face.
And that might be involved in the
evolutionary series that gave rise
to our species, and out
particular kind of face.
For various reasons, I couldn't
start on the book, right away.
Having to do with work
and other projects.
And I didn't really start on
it in a serious way until 2011.
And it was a good thing that
I waited, because in a sense,
there was very little known
when I first had the idea.
By the time I got started
on the book,
there was a great deal
more information.
So, in effect, the field had caught
up with my ambitions to write
about it, which was nice.
Okay. So, let us.
I'll just add one more thing.
That is that in the sense, as I
worked on the book I found the focus
of my interest changing, somewhat,
from that of how the genes
that are involved in
making the human face.
How they'd evolved and how
their expression characteristics
had changed.
More to the why of this.
What was it in our
evolutionary history,
the evolution of our species,
that really has made
us the species we are?
So, while my official title for
this talk is ''Making Faces,
the Evolutionary Origins
of the Human Face'',
The alternative title
gives more of a hint
as to what I'm going to focus on.
How our evolving face
helped make us human.
Okay. So, let us begin
with a basic question.
What precisely do we
mean by the face?
Now, we all recognize faces.
And even in this sort
of caricature of form,
that is Clerdia [phonetic] face.
But how do we define the face?
It's always good to start with a
clear definition of one's subject.
And briefly, the face is the forward
directed part of the animal's head
with a mouth and three
kinds of sense organs
for vision, smell, and taste.
Forward directed means the
face is set in the direction
of movement of the animal.
So, our faces do, indeed, look
forward toward the environment
that the animal is entering.
And what I have here, is pictures
represented of vertebrates.
So, we are in the group of
animals termed the vertebrates,
which are a subdivision of a
major group called the Chordata.
We needn't go into
those details very much.
But the vertebrates, all
the animals with backbones,
consist of about 50,000 species.
Which is roughly a
half to one percent
of all the estimated existing
animal species in the world.
Still, 50,000 is a big number.
And all vertebrates have
faces, as you can see, here.
We cannot see the sensor
organs very directly,
in this, but of course, you can.
Well, except for the eyes.
So, what we have here, is a fish,
an amphibian, a reptile, bird.
And two of my favorite
mammalian species, wolves and us.
And they all have eyes and some sort
of visible nostrils for olfaction.
We can't see the organs of taste,
because they're within the mouth.
So, another way of putting this,
is to say that the face is the
sensory headquarters of the animal.
Okay. It's a really concentrated
area of the animal's body,
that had three of the main
kinds of sensor organs.
With, of course, the organs of
hearing, just behind the face.
And they are in close
association with the mouth.
Now, why is the face
constructed this way?
Well, we get a clue from considering
the evidence that we have
on the earliest vertebrates,
which were tiny fish.
And they did, indeed, have,
from everything we know.
Of course, we don't know directly
about their organs of
taste and olfaction.
But they had two eyes in
association with the mouth.
And this must have been, for them,
a tremendous aid to being able
to find food and to ingest it.
To have the eyes and the organs
of olfaction near the mouth,
helps the animal, of
course, to find food.
If you imagine the eyes and the
organs of olfaction back here,
you can see that they wouldn't
be nearly as useful to the animal
for finding food, as if they were
in close association with the mouth.
So, having defined the face,
let's come to the question
of what makes the human face
particularly worth talking about?
Is it just because it's
the face of our species?
Quite naturally, we are
interested in things
that relate directly to us.
Just as most of us are more
interested in our family
and friends, than people
down the block,
whom we might see most every day.
But whom we don't know
anything about.
So, is the face primarily
interesting just
because it is our face?
Or is it, in fact, something, a
rather special and unusual face?
And I'm going to argue,
briefly, that it is, indeed,
a very special and interesting face.
So, to answer this question.
If you're going to argue
there's something special,
it's got to be special in
comparison to something else.
And so, we need to compare it,
in this case, with other faces.
And let's just focus on the mammals,
which is our major subgroup
within the vertebrates.
So, first of all, let me just admit
that there are some very
interesting, unusual,
indeed special, faces
amongst mammals.
And we have an assortment
of these, here.
No need to go into details.
You can see, immediately,
that they're not like you cat
or your dog, which are
more typical mammals.
But the great majority of
mammals actually do have a kind
of typical generic face.
There are 18 divisions within
the mammals, called orders.
Okay. It's a taxonomic term.
And I've shown here, typical members
of eight different
orders of mammals.
And if I pick the examples from
most of the other orders of mammals,
it would be a similar picture.
The features that the typical
mammal has, are a muscle.
Okay. Rather well-spaced eyes.
Fur on the face.
You can see that in all of these.
And no real forehead.
The head sort of slopes back,
gently, from just above the eyes.
And those are the features
that make for a commonality
in the faces of most mammals.
And once one has realized
that, one sees that, in fact,
even amongst some of the
oddballs that I showed earlier.
Some of them have at least one
or two of those common features.
And without going into
the details, though,
just you know, make that point.
But having accepted that fact
that there is this set
of common features.
We then come to the
rather surprising fact,
that one of the most
unusual mammalian faces,
is that of homo sapiens.
That's ourselves.
Okay. And since most of us in this
room tend to think of the human face
as the prototypical,
hence, normal face.
It may be a surprise to think
that we actually have a very odd
and different animal face.
So, instead of just your
taking my word for this claim,
that our face is particularly
unusual.
I decided to quote an authority,
here, a man named Donald Enlow.
I'm not sure if he's still alive.
But he is or was one
of the great experts
on the craniofacial skeleton.
In other words, the skull
and the bones of the face.
And here, I'll just read out,
even though you can read it.
I'll read it out.
''The human face is different.
Bu ordinary mammalian standards,
our facial features are unusual,
specialized, and perhaps
even grotesque.
The long functional
muscle that marks the face
of most other mammalian forms,
is all but lacking in man.
The associated snout is reduced
to a curious overhanging
vestige.'' Known as our nose.
''The face is wide, flat, and
vertically disposed.'' Okay.
We have these flat, and indeed,
vertically disposed faces.
''instead of graceful facial contour
sloping back to the skull roof,
the human face possesses a unique
bulbous, upright forehead in front
of an enormous braincase.
The flattened face is diminutive in
character relative to the remainder
of the enlarged head.''
So, our faces are small,
relative to that of
most other mammals.
''The eyes are close together
and they face straight forward.
The human dental arches are
disproportionately small relative
to the size of the whole body.'' In
other words, we have smaller teeth.
Okay. Indeed, the physical
features of our face are unusual.
And for an evolutionary
biologist, that's interesting.
But what makes the human face
truly unusual is not its structure,
but its behavior.
And specifically, its capacity
for different expressions,
as illustrated here.
Okay. Now, there are
altogether seven basic strong
human expressions.
And one is neutral.
Okay. Where you're not
showing any particular emotion.
Anger, disgust, fear,
happiness, sadness,
and surprise shown
in that order, here.
The lines under the line drawns,
indicate the tension lines
from the muscles in the face
that create these expressions.
I'll have a bit more to say about
the facial muscles, in a moment.
So, most mammas do not
have this great range
of expressions, of
strong expressions.
And certainly, the other
vertebrates; fish, amphibians,
reptiles, birds, do not
have anywhere near this.
And I'll come back to the
why of that, in a moment.
But some of our nearest, and I'm
tempted to say dearest relatives,
the great apes, in fact do
have large expressive capacity.
As shown here, in this comparison.
And you can make really
a very good judgment
that the strong expressions
they show.
Which can often be likened
to particular human expressions
accompanying certain emotions,
really reflect those emotions,
because of the context.
The chimpanzee happiness
expression occurs
when the animal is really
showing some pleasure
in the animals it's
interacting with.
Or whatever.
So, it's not pure anthropomorphism,
by a long shot.
But these very expressive
animals, chimps, bonobos,
gorillas a little bit less,
orangutans a little bit less.
But these very facially expressive
animals don't have quite the full
range of expressions that we do.
And this is just a
small illustration
of more subtle expressions
that our species exhibits.
And one of the nice things, is that
almost everybody in this audience,
and in fact I'm sure
everybody in this audience.
Can read these expressions and
understand something of the emotions
that this person is
experiencing and displaying
in each of these situations.
And altogether, there
are something like,
I don't know the precise number.
There are people who study this.
This is a whole large
area of research.
There's something like 50 of
these so-called minor expressions.
And that's a great number.
So, I'm not going to make the claim
that we are the most facially
expressive animal on earth.
Okay. And I stress facially,
because other animals
really have different ways
of expressing their feelings
through body language.
That is, body language
below the head.
Through sound and other ways.
But facially, we are the most
expressive animal on earth.
And I say that, not only
because of this great range
of expressions we have that our
nearest animal cousins don't have.
And there are scientific ways
to measure this, I should add.
It's a method called FACS, which we
need not go into in detail, here.
But by using FACS,
you can actually look
at the expressions in other animals.
And this has been done
with chimpanzees and dogs.
And they really do by these
measurements, by this technique,
they really are less
expressive than we are,
in the range of what they do.
But in addition, the
frequency of our expressions,
I think we are probably the
most expressive animal on earth,
because we are talking animals.
And when we talk to each
other, there is a play
of expressions on our face.
And if you watch any two people
having a conversation for any length
of time, more than just hello
goodbye, you will see this play
of expressions as a
kind of shadow dialog.
And even if you can't hear the
words, you can tell something
about the feelings that are being
expressed accompanying the words.
So, this raises an interesting
evolutionary question,
''How did we become this
super-expressive animal using our
faces?'' So, the basic biological
foundation of this is a whole set
of muscles, called
the mimetic muscles,
and these are diagrammed, here.
And again, we need not
go into the details.
The key point is that the
mimetic muscles are found only
in the mammals.
And that's why the other vertebrates
aren't near as expressive.
They don't have the capacity to
move their skin on their faces,
in the way that we mammals do
with these mimetic muscles.
The face is the only
place on the mammal's body
where there's a direct connection
to the skin for moving the skin.
Okay. And it's a mammalian
specialty.
Now, other mammals have
many of these muscles.
Many of the mammals that are not
primates don't have the full set.
But our nearest relatives
do have the full set,
the gorillas and the chimpanzees.
So, the fact that they are perhaps
somewhat less facially expressive,
is not due to difference
in the muscles.
But it must be due to either the
way the muscles are innervated
or the mental processes that
activate the expressions.
And I think it's the latter,
though in this lecture I won't
be able to document this.
Just as I won't be able to document
many of the things that I say.
But I go into them in the book.
And of course, we'll be glad to
take questions on that, at the end.
So, having this whole set of complex
muscles isn't the sole explanation
for why we're such an
expressive species.
But these are the elements
of our anatomy
that make those expressions
possible.
So, let us now come to the
evolutionary questions.
And the big one is, or
the first big one is,
''What were the major changes
that led from fish faces
to the human face?'' And as I
mentioned, the first fishes evolved
around 500 million years, ago.
And there is clearly a
great deal of difference
between this face and this face.
Even though they are basic faces by
the criteria that I've mentioned.
So, let us first look at
the general time scale.
And then, we're going to
home in on this period
when the first primates arrived.
So, I've spoken of us as mammals.
We are, indeed, mammals.
But we're within one special group
of the mammals, the primates.
And the distinctive changes
that have evolved in our lineage
that have made our face what it is,
all arose in this relatively
short period.
But let's look at the whole period
in which animals have existed.
So, first of all, the
earth is estimated
to be 4.5 billion years old, and
this is a fairly well-agreed figure.
The first animals didn't appear
until only 600 million years, ago.
So, about the last 12%
of the planet's history.
These first animals were actually
very strange and not easily related
to more contemporary mammals.
But the first vertebrates
and many of the modern kinds
of animals originated here, starting
about 540 million years, ago.
The first vertebrates
from their fossils,
date to about 500 million
years, ago, as I mentioned.
The first true mammals,
okay, animals that have fur
and whose females produce
milk for their young,
those are the key criteria
for making a mammal.
Arose in the Jurassic
period, the age of dinosaurs.
Maybe, 180 to 150 million
years, ago.
The first primates, which are
our mammalian mother group,
arose about 60 million years, ago.
And we humans arose, our species,
arose only 200,000 years, ago.
So, if one were to take this
whole 600-million-year period
for the existence of
animals, our species arose.
If you were to take
that as a 24-hour day,
our species arose in
the last two minutes.
Okay. We are really very
recently evolved animals
by a number of strong criteria.
Okay. We can make that statement
with reasonable definitiveness.
Now, there were humanlike
species, earlier,
going back to roughly
2 million years, ago.
But that's still only about the
last ten minutes of a 24-hour day.
Okay. But what we will
want to look at now,
is how the particular features
that make our face special.
Some which I enumerated, earlier
in that quote from Don Enlow.
They all arose during
this 60-year period.
And specifically.
Here, let me backtrack.
Let's just look at one early
change, which is important.
And then, I'll take you
through a quick run-through
of a lot of evolutionary history.
And then, we'll start
focusing on the primates.
So, the first vertebrates arose
about 500 million years, ago.
There were further changes.
The big change was
the evolution of jaws.
And here, I'm not talking about
the movie star eating shark.
But these elements which
allow us to chew our food.
The evolution of jaws
probably happened only once.
It was a somewhat unlikely
evolutionary event.
But it really opened up the
capacity of our line of animals
to ingest many different
kinds of food.
Had we remained jawless
fish, like this,
probably the vertebrates
would never have expanded
in the way that they or we have.
Okay. Now, here is a very quick
run-through of vertebrate history
that will just take
us up to the primates,
which is what we're interested in.
Because it's within the primates
that our distinctive
form of face arose.
So, about 300 million years,
ago, there were lobe finned fish,
which were the precursors
of the first land dwelling
animals, the amphibians.
Amphibians gave rise to a number
of other land-living forms.
In particular, the branch that
gave rise to the dinosaurs.
And another branch
called the Synapsids,
which gave rise to the mammals.
And indeed, these have been
called the mammal-like reptiles.
The look very.
This is Dimetrodon, a
famous early animal,
sometimes mistakenly
called a dinosaur.
It was not.
It was a Synapsid.
And its key feature, which
you can't really see here,
that made it mammal-like,
was its different dentition.
There then, followed further changes
in which these more
reptilian-looking animals gave rise
to mammals.
And finally, there
were true mammals.
The date of true mammals, the
first dates are a little bit vague,
depending upon what you
define as a true mammal.
But let's say about
150 million years, ago.
Whereas, the modern forms of
mammals are more recent than that.
And here, just to give
you some time sense
of when mammalian features
started arising.
This is Dimetrodon, about
290 million years, ago.
This is Cynognathus, an
early mammal-like form,
only 210 million years, ago.
So, about 80 million years.
Mammals clearly had their
own line of descent.
So, a lot of this evolution
is summarized in this book.
This is the first general account
of the evolution of the face,
by a man named William K. Gregory,
who was a curator at the Museum
of Natural History, in New York.
And this is his classic book,
''Our Face from Fish to Man''.
It was written in the aftermath of
the Scopes Trial, the famous trial
which had as its issue, the question
of whether evolution should
be taught in the schools.
And this is a famous trial involving
famous lawyers, Charles Darrow
and William Jennings Bryan, two
major figures in American history.
So, Gregory wrote this
book as a defense
of the existence of evolution.
And his take-home message was
this; ''the basic structure
of vertebrate face has
stayed much the same,
despite many changes in the details.
Over 400 million years from the
early jawed fish to humans''.
And that is, undoubtedly, true.
Here we have a fish skull with a
fish face and the rest of the skull.
Here is a lion skull.
And even though, of course, at one
level these look very different,
in their fundamental
structure, they're much the same.
So, along with its basic structure,
the vertebrate face has retained its
central function from fish to man,
as sensory headquarters
plus the mouth.
Despite all the changes in details
of structure in numerable species.
Okay. So, the organs of smell and
taste and vision are much the same
in most mammalian faces, in their
location and their basic function,
as in some of the early
vertebrates, which were fish.
Okay. So, let's now come to the
primates, which is our mother group,
in which the distinctive
characteristics
of the human face arose.
And I'm not going to go into the
details of mammalian evolution.
We're just focusing on the primates.
One so-called taxonomic
order out of 18.
And let us look at the.
So, we are primates.
And let us look at the earliest
primates, from which we arrived.
And there are different views.
You know, we're trying
to reconstruct things
that happened roughly 60
to 65 million years, ago.
So, there are not living
eyewitnesses.
So, it involves a matter
of scientific reconstruction
[inaudible].
And there are different views.
From Robert Martin who is
one of the great experts
on primate evolution,
we have this view.
From another group, we
have something closer to.
We have a depiction that is
an alternative depiction.
In a way, I'm cheating,
because this is presumed
to be the earliest placental mammal.
But the primates arose.
Almost certainly arose quickly,
as a separate group from something
that might have looked like this.
So, they might not have
looked that different.
The important point is that whether
you accept this view as closer
to the reality of the
earliest primate, or this one,
these are typical mammalian faces.
Okay. As I showed, earlier, where
there is a projecting snout,
there's fur on the face,
and a few other features.
So, let us now look at the
diversification of the primates
and see where the changes came in,
that helped to make the human face.
And this is a picture
of the evolutionary
or phylogenetic tree
of the primates.
And there are two basic
groups, called the prosimians
and the anthropoid primates.
And we are definitely a member
of the anthropoid primates.
And the split between these two
major branches occurred probably
around 55, maybe 60
million years, ago.
So, the ancestral primates,
whether they looked like either
of the versions I showed you,
were existing at least here.
Maybe around 63 million years, ago.
And maybe, before.
And then, they split
into the prosimians
and the anthropoid primates.
And this is where the first
major set of changes that led
to the human face took place.
And we'll come to the second
set of changes, in a moment.
But let's look at the first.
So, here is a prosimian, which
despite some exotic details
like the ruff, looks very
much like the other mammals
that form the majority of mammals.
There is a projecting snout,
the eyes are very wide apart,
there is fur on the face.
Here are two anthropoid primates.
And all of the so-called
anthropoid primates,
and we belong to this
large division.
Anthropoid means man-like.
Have these distinguishing features.
They have close-set
forward-looking eyes.
Notice these eyes are definitely
more close-set than these.
The anthropoid primates have
a naked or furless face.
And they have a reduced
muzzle, compared to the others.
So, the net result of this
first set of physical changes,
which probably took place
roughly 50 million years, ago,
is that the anthropoid primate
face is far more expressive
than the prosimian face.
Okay. Just by virtue of
the face being naked,
you can see the skin more clearly in
naked faces, than in furred faces.
And it is therefore, more
expressive of the feelings,
intentions, and simple thoughts.
Okay. So, this is the first step
forward toward a human face.
And I think we can
see that these faces
of the anthropoid primates are,
indeed, more humanlike than this,
which looks more like
a typical mammal.
So, the first major set of changes
took place roughly 50 million years,
ago, changes that led in the
direction of the human face.
And the second phase of
major changes leading
to modern human face, including
ultimately anatomically modern
humans, shown here by this figure.
Took place much later.
Roughly starting about four
to 6 million years, ago.
And here, I've just
sketched it very crudely.
Now, we don't know what the
absolutely ancestral hominin,
this means the humanlike
primates, looked like.
But the modern chimpanzee
is probably not too far off.
There are debates about what the
resemblances and differences are.
But we can take a modern chimp
as a crude representative
of the earliest member of the
branch that led to humans.
And we see some of
the changes, here.
I'm not going to go
into them in detail.
But I think you can see
that this modern human face,
which is a bushman
from South Africa.
Really is a smaller face
than these longer faces
of these more apelike
humanlike creatures.
It's a smaller face,
it's flat, it's vertical.
There isn't really
any sign of a muzzle.
Okay. There's a broad forehead.
Okay. So, what were the major
changes in the second stage?
The complete loss of the muzzle in.
You know, the complete
loss of the muzzle.
Flattening and verticalization
of the face.
So, we really have vertical faces,
unlike faces that have
projecting snout.
The gain of the forehead and
behind that, our big brain.
And I'm now going to concentrate on
this, because it's quite important.
One, it really has changed
our look as an animal.
And secondly, this is connected
to the growth of our big brain,
which has certainly been a major
contributor to the fact that we are
such a facially expressive animal.
And that those expressions
have played a huge part
in our evolution a
what we are, today.
So, one of the driving forces, or
one of the trains in our evolution,
has been the increasing brain size,
shown here fairly diagrammatically.
And these are inferred
brains, because of course,
the brains themselves
haven't been preserved.
What we have is the skulls.
And from the skulls you
can reconstruct some
of the surface features
of the brain.
But these are, as I say,
somewhat imaginative depictions
of the changes in brain size
that have occurred in the course
of our developing from
the first hominins.
The first humanlike animals,
over roughly, 6 million years.
So, what drove the increase
in human brain size?
This is really an important
and interesting question
that's fundamental
to understanding human evolution.
The first key point is that
something must have driven this,
because brains are expensive.
Expensive in terms of energy, hence,
in the amount of nutrients
that we have to take in.
The comprise only about
two percent of body weight,
which doesn't sound
like a large percentage.
But it's a relatively
large amount for an animal.
But they require 20% of the
energy needed by the body.
Okay. So, brains are
energetically expensive.
And that makes demands on the
animal for adequate nutrition.
Okay. So, there are three
general explanations.
I'm going to run through
them fairly quickly
and not do any of them real justice.
But just to sketch them out.
There's the better
nutrition hypothesis.
The need for greater intelligence
for foraging and hunting.
And finally, the third hypothesis
is that it the growing array
of social interactions,
something known
as the social brain hypothesis, that
drove the increase in brain size.
So, the better nutrition hypothesis.
There are several variants of this.
I think one of the favorite ones
comes from Richard Wrangham,
who is a professor at Harvard, and
a friend and colleague of mine.
And essentially, is that when humans
learned how to cook they were able
to increase the efficiency
with which they extracted
calories from food.
And there's a lot of
evidence for this.
But it's not clear to me that
simply having more easier access
to more energy would have driven
the increase in brain size.
I think the more plausible
explanation is
that there were pressures for
increased complexity of behaviors
and various brain related functions.
Which required better nutrition.
But the better nutrition itself,
which he has emphasized
comes from cooking.
And cooking [inaudible] releases
more readily available energy.
I think that simply the availability
of more energy by cooking food,
probably does not explain
the increase in brain size.
And there are other
variance of this hypothesis,
but they all emphasize
increased energy availability
from foods as the driving force.
So, I think that this is unlikely.
I would say it's an
insufficient reason
to explain the increase
in brain size.
What about the need for
greater intelligence
for foraging and hunting?
There's no question that foraging
and hunting as humans do it,
it often more sophisticated,
even often a much more
sophisticated way of getting food.
Than the way most of our
brother animals get their food.
Including our nearest
relatives amongst the primates.
So, I think that for
various reasons,
which I'm not going to detail here.
I think that this is
unconvincing as the prime driver
of what has made our brains bigger.
This is unconvincing as the major
selective force for larger brains.
What about the third one?
The growing array of
social interactions?
The social brain hypothesis.
There isn't time to
go into all of this,
but there is a great
deal of support for it.
That it was the growing
complexity of social interactions,
whether in raising offspring,
in interacting with each other.
That may have been the driving
force in driving brain growth.
So, in my opinion, this is the best.
And it's inextricably bound up
with the idea of social selection.
Namely, the idea that social
interactions strengthen
social cohesion.
Which promotes the survival
of the group, and thereby,
of its individual members.
And here I've allowed myself
to give one reference.
This idea has, I think, not
really been given enough play.
But this idea was first explained
by a guy named Herbert Simon,
who is an economist,
not a biologist.
But somebody with a
very great range.
And the idea simply is that we are
necessarily a cooperative species.
Certainly, in our early
days, we needed a lot
of cooperation to get things done.
You take the human and put him
or her out on his or her own,
and that person's survival
will be rapidly compromised.
We are inherently a social animal
and we need our social
cohesion, in order to survive.
I realize that I'm not giving
this argument in its full details
and merits, but that's
just because of time.
But I would recommend if anybody's
interested in following it up,
looking at this article
by Herbert Simon.
Now, three key points to
that social selection.
It's not the same as
group selection.
Group selection posits that certain
things evolved because they were
for the good of the group.
Instead, the idea of
social selection posits
that there was strength in social
bonds that were a direct benefit
to the individual,
often at minimal cost.
Okay. Again, that deserves
more explanation
than I can give it, here.
But that is a key idea.
For humans, the evolution of
social interactions must have been,
to some degree, coupled with
the evolution of language.
Okay. It's hard to convey your wish
to do things cooperatively
without language.
You can do it to some
extent, and animals do.
But language had almost undoubtedly
been of crucial importance
in our evolution as a species.
Finally, the evolution of
language was almost certainly tied
up with both the evolution
of the brain
and of facial expressions
accompanying speech.
But faces, in that last point,
we come back to the face.
That facial expressions
are in speech, in a sense,
a fundamental part of what
we communicate by speech.
And if you think about your
own reactions to people,
you'll understand that that's true.
As I mentioned, every
prolonged dialog
between people involves a
play of facial expressions,
as well as the words
that are conveyed.
And that's why it's often much
more effective to talk with someone
about something that's
difficult face-to-face,
than by email, for example.
Okay. Faces convey much information
about an individual in addition
to that about mood and feelings.
Faces provide visual
information about gender.
Okay. Age.
Admittedly, I've chosen those
examples to maximize the contrast.
There may also be a size
difference between these two people.
But even just from the photographs,
you know, that you're looking
at a baby, here, a
very young person.
And an older person, there.
Ethnicity, as an example.
And character.
Now, this is the most tricky
and perhaps the most ambiguous.
So, to weight the scales,
I've contrasted Abraham
Lincoln with Rasputin.
But. And there are some
wonderful pictures of Rasputin,
in which his eyes look
positively crazy.
But I think even if you didn't
know anything about the history.
The historical importance
of these people,
these two individuals
and what they were like.
I think that if you saw lots of
pictures of Lincoln and of this man,
you would conclude that this
man was, indeed, more trustable.
It really comes through
in his facial expressions
and the set of his face.
Okay. So, the face provides a
tremendous amount of information
to our fellows, often
just at a glance.
And these are an important part
of our social interactions.
So, faces provide an
instant visual identification
of a particular individual.
In effect, of the 7.3
billion people on earth today,
there are about that many
distinguishable faces.
Of course, identical twins
and triplets are an exception.
But, indeed, most human faces
are at least slightly different
from other faces, and
often very different.
So, and rapid visual
identification is an invaluable aid
in social interactions.
And this is just an obvious
point, when you walk into a room,
you look for people you know.
You do it almost immediately,
from their face.
Yes, there may be hints about from
their size or body build, and so on.
But the face is the main
provider of information
about who you're looking for.
So, is there an evolutionary
explanation for facial differences?
Yes. If facial differences provide
quick individual identification,
and if that identification
promotes social interactions,
most of which are positive, helpful.
Then, it will be selection
for such differences.
Now, there is actually beginning to
be a genetics of facial difference.
I'm going to just go over this very
lightly, because I think it gets
into too much detail for
the time I have allowed.
I'm not even sure if
I've exceeded that time.
So, I'm just going to leave this
with you as a specific point.
That it's now possible to identify
specific genetic differences
as correlating with individual
specific facial differences.
There is beginning to be a true
genetics of facial difference.
There are at least, at this point,
20 genes that are identified
with specific facial differences.
And at some point, just from
sequenced genomes, alone.
And the genes that are involved
in creating facial differences,
one may be able to actually
reconstruct what the faces looked
like form their genetic differences.
This is really, it's
still for the future,
but it's within the realm
of possibility, now.
So, with those findings, can
facial differences be related
to social selection?
Namely, selection for individuals
within a particular social context.
Almost certainly.
A new work shows that
quantitatively,
faces are indeed more
morphologically diverse
than other regions of the body.
Okay. So, our faces
show more differences
than any other part of our body.
The genes implicated in
generating facial differences are
under selection to be different.
The phenomena of negative frequency
dependent selection, or NFDS.
This is an awkward term
and we can forget it.
But the important point
is that it seems
that there actually is selection
for us to have different faces,
so that we can recognize
each other very quickly.
And this only makes sense in terms
of facial difference actually
promoting interactions
that are ultimately helpful.
This point could be elaborated
a lot, and it's interesting.
But there isn't time.
So, I'm now coming to the close of
the lecture and just summing up.
So, what was the major net
effect of the changes that led
from fish faces to the human face?
So, let's first just
look at fish faces.
And it's not just fish faces,
but the faces shown by fish,
amphibia, reptiles, and birds.
The four major classes apart
from the mammals, amongst
the vertebrates.
The animals with backbones.
So, these faces were, indeed, the
sensory headquarters of the animal.
And the site of food
ingestion in the mouth.
Primarily, the face
existed as a receiver
of information about the world.
And initially, for the
animal to find food.
Now, with the mammals, there began
to be real facial expressions,
and hence, information to other
members of the same species
about what was going on in the mind
of the animal making
these expressions.
So, there were the
same functions as found
in the other kinds of vertebrates.
Plus, the face is the provider
of some information to others.
And with us, in the genus homo,
and specifically our own
species, homo sapiens.
There were all the same
original functions of the face.
Okay. For locating food and so on.
Plus, it was a provider.
The face has become a
provider of huge amounts
of information about the individual.
And this is of social value.
The face is a storehouse and
transmitter of information.
Okay. So, the earliest vertebrate
face is where primarily receivers.
Sorry, were primarily receivers
of information about the world.
And of course, as a site
of ingestion for food.
Our face is certainly a storehouse
of information about the face.
But it also conveys that information
to the fellow members
of our species.
It's a fairly fundamental
difference.
And of course, as I've
stressed, this is shared
with our nearest relatives.
But also, to some extent, with
more distant mammalian relatives.
But we've taken it to an extreme.
So, summing up, I'll
just read this out.
''For about 450 million years
of evolutionary history,
the faces of vertebrates
functioned primarily
as the sensory headquarters
of the individual''.
Okay. The concentrated
areas in which three
of the main senses are localized.
Initially, and particularly the
search for and ingestion of food.
Furthermore, a point that I
haven't really elaborated,
but I'll state it, here.
''Matters of diet influenced
the shape of jaws and teeth
and the placement of
the sensory apparatus.
And therefore, the shape
and structure of the face''.
Okay. So, matters of
diet were really crucial
in shaping the evolution of the
face for most of vertebrate history.
''For 50 or so million years, in the
anthropoid primates'', specifically,
''the social environment
played an increasing role.
Becoming even stronger and
more complex in the hominins''.
The hominins being our group.
''Thus, social selection
played a major part
in shaping the human face
in all its unusualness.
We are the most sociable of animals.
And the physical characteristics
of the human face reflect
a long history
of increasingly complex
social interactions''.
And that in a sense, is the
main message from this talk.
But I'd like to end with
an additional thought.
And even a bit of advice.
And that is that the
capacity of our face to give
out information is incredibly
valuable and unusual.
And more than 50 million years
of anthropoid primate evolution
have been invested, in a sense.
Not by anybody deliberately
making it so, it just happened.
Have been 50 million years of
primate evolution have been invested
to make our faces superb instruments
for communicating our
thoughts and feelings.
I urge you to take advantage
of that, as much as possible.
If you want to communicate something
important and/or complex to someone,
do it face-to-face, not by email.
At least by Skype.
Okay. And I think with
that, I'll close.
So, thank you, very
much, for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Mr. Wilkins.
>> Adam Wilkins: Yes.
>> Can you explain exactly
how the genetic selection
[inaudible]difference from
other people [inaudible]
or facial characteristics
[inaudible]?
>> Adam Wilkins: Yeah.
So, I think you're asking me
what is negative frequency
dependent selection.
This is the awkward term.
How can there be selection
for difference?
And it depends on.
I think in this case, certainly,
it depends on people
perceiving difference
and finding it attractive.
So, we all know.
So, it comes into probably
what's termed sexual selection,
where there is a special set of
things that influence the selection
of characteristics that
have to do with mating.
Whom you want to link up with.
And so, it's almost certainly
something that has been.
And I think it's almost
certain, this preference
for slight difference is connected
with what we find attractive
in others.
This point hasn't yet, has not
received a lot of attention.
The main findings that
really support this idea,
came out only a year or two, ago,
from a guy named Michael Shin, who.
Yeah, Shin, who is a professor
at Cornell University.
So, I think that's all
I can say about it.
But basically, it comes down to
the fact that people like a degree
of difference, when
selecting their mates.
And this has the side effect of
helping to make us all different.
Which has the important
additional value
that in social interactions
we can identify each other,
much more readily.
Without this negative
frequency dependent selection,
we might be tending
to be more homogenous.
There would be less
facial difference
and more similarity, time.
But here we are, standing at 7.3
billion people on earth with nearly
that many different and
discernably different faces.
And it must have something to
do with the fact that difference
in our perspective mates,
slight facial differences
often are attractive.
I'm not sure I can say anything
more about it, than that.
But that's the rough idea.
Yes. Oh, sorry.
>> There was a lot [inaudible].
Public channel, or something
like that, about what makes,
I guess humans attracted
to one another.
But not just humans.
But right now, my question
is about this thing
that they said about
facial symmetry.
>> Adam Wilkins: Mm-hmm.
>> They were really talking about
people who are looking for mates
who are the healthiest and the most
likely to propagate the species.
>> Adam Wilkins: Yes.
>> But that so what they were
looking for was [inaudible].
Facial symmetry and
a chart that showed
that some actor had
like their perfect face.
>> Adam Wilkins: Yes.
>> That they [inaudible].
But that instead of
looking for differences,
they were actually looking
for like a [inaudible] was the
perfect healthiest.
>> Adam Wilkins: So, this idea is
what I believe, and there's a lot
of supporting evidence for it.
That a symmetrical face is really,
highly symmetrical faces are
more attractive to members
of the opposite sex, than
more visibly asymmetric faces.
So, there is a fair amount of
scientific data supporting this.
I'm not sure I'm equipped to
say anything more than that.
But that comes into it.
Does that help answer your question?
Or?
>> Well, I just sort of
[inaudible] that [inaudible].
>> Adam Wilkins: It's
a slightly different.
Yeah.
>> Selections.
>> Adam Wilkins: Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
I think the idea, in general,
is that more symmetric
faces indicate kind
of a better construction
of the person as a whole.
And I think we all know that we find
more symmetrical faces inherently
more attractive than more
visibly asymmetric ones.
And that must affect the likelihood
with which one can mate with others.
Yes.
>> Did I hear you say?
Did I correctly hear you say
that thought processes
helped to shape the brain?
And if so, how did they do that?
>> Adam Wilkins: Well, I'm
not sure I said exactly that.
But thought processes
certainly affect our behavior.
And our behaviors then, our,
in the sense of animals.
And an animal's behavior will
affect how well it survives.
And hence, you know, whether it's
likely to have more progeny or not.
Does that help out?
>> [inaudible] actually
affect the physical structure?
>> Adam Wilkins: So,
it's indirect, okay.
So, there's a selection for
neural superstructure that permits
or promotes certain
kinds of behaviors.
Which in turn, are either
more favorable or less
for promoting the survival
of the animal.
So, it's an indirect way
of affecting the likelihood
of selection for an animal
with those properties.
Yes.
>> I understand that humans evolved
in small groups of maybe 100 or so.
>> Adam Wilkins: Yes.
>> Individuals.
>> And so, it seems to me,
listening to your discussion,
that we only need to distinguish
about 100 different facial
arrangements, something like that.
According to the evolutionary
analysis.
And so, in the modern world where
you're living in cities of millions,
you have to have social
evolution to contribute
to the distinctiveness
of all the individuals.
And my thinking, as you're talking,
is that you've also explained
the evolution of all kinds
of social phenomena, like
[inaudible] for instance.
I don't know what [inaudible].
>> Adam Wilkins: Yes.
So, we are used to a
world of cities and towns
and large numbers of people.
Most of the evolution I've
discussed occurred when the groups
of humans were much smaller.
But there's undoubtedly,
evolutionary selection going on,
today, in these very
large mixed groups.
I mean, what we have, today,
is really unprecedented
in the evolution of our
species, or indeed, any species.
This going from small interactive
groups to potentially huge ones.
So, does that pertain
to what you're saying?
I'm.
>> I wasn't thinking of
that, but that's okay.
Because I can see that [inaudible].
>> Tomoko Steen: You
can [inaudible].
>> Adam Wilkins: Yeah.
But.
>> Judging from your
facial features.
[ Laughter ]
>> Yes.
>> Tomoko Steen: Please join me
to thank today's speaker, again.
Thank you, very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.